GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE HEARING --
AT SEEING A QUORUM WHICH IS SIX
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
HERE MATHIS THEIR I YEAR CURRY
HERE [inaudible]
FLORA HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
THERE IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER LEVINE [inaudible]
SALAS PRESIDENT.
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
MINUTE TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR AND WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH THE HEARING.
MADAM CHAIR TICKET YOU WERE
PREPARED TO PRESENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY TO FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY TO FIFTY TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IS OMNIBUS ANIMAL
HEALTH BILL. FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVED
OUTDATED LANGUAGE DEALING WITH
DISEASED ANIMALS AND EXPAND TO
CAN BE FINED FOR KNOWINGLY
MOVING A DISEASED ANIMAL OUT OF
A QUARANTINE ZONE WITHOUT PROPER
PERMISSION.
AND UPDATED LANGUAGE RELATING TO
EQUINE DRUGS THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CRISTINA KARA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE BLOOD BANK
CLEANUP WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE TO SHARE AND TO
MISTER FRANK OF ITS FOR HIS
HELP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHECK
REALLY* GREENBERG TRAURIG ON
BEHALF OF ONE OF THE TWO
LICENSED BLOOD BANKS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE ANIMAL
BLOOD BANK IN SUPPORT OF FOR THE
BLOOD BANK PROVISIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
AFTER JASON BRIDE OF AB WESTERN
AYE DURING AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
--
PRIME RECENTLY HAVE COMFORTABLY
FEDERATION SUPPORT.
AND TO THE COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR
TO SMALLVILLE THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORT.
THINKING.
SEE NO THERE'S AND SUPPORTING ME
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION OR
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND SIR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN HOW
THEY ARE ALL I COME THE ORAL AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE A YEAR
CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER.
GRAY.
GRAY EYES GRAY AYE HER WHEN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE.
LIVING AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE MEASURES CONCURRED IN.
OUR SEARCHER PLEASE LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THEY VERY MUCH
.
THOUGH WE GET AT LEAST
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
BASS.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE AGAIN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ABSENT MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I JONES SAWYER
SO THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED